this was not an easy role for him and
you you recognized something in Hackman
that profoundly affected his performance
in the way that you directed him Jean
wanted to be in the film very much and
but he had no idea how far I was going
to take Egan and Jean was born in a
small town in Illinois called Dundee
Chris and Dundee had been a Ku Klux Klan
town in the old days and it was a
blue-collar town and jeans father had
deserted the family when Jean was very
young and so Jean grew up disliking
authority and he disliked racism and he
felt when I sent him to go around with
eddie egan as I did he felt that Egan
was just a racist and he didn't want to
go there and I recognized this and I
knew that even though I was the youngest
guy on the set
I was the authority figure on this set
and so I worked with Hackman in a way
that I've never worked with anyone else
I would I would I knew I had to get him
angry and so I would it's really
embarrassing I'm but I would say things
to Jean like we do a shot and I like one
take I love one take because it's so
spontaneous and Jean wouldn't go the
distance with Hackman with eddie egan
and i would instead of saying cut I
would say oh Jesus Christ it's are you
kidding me I would say pal you better
get a day job you know you you better
look for something else because this
isn't working out and he actually quit
the film in on the second day
and his agent sue mangers said well
that's fine gene if you do that you'll
own the picture you know you alone
everything they've spent so Jean stuck
around and stuck it out but I would get
his anger to a point where he would
finish a take filled with rage and then
walk off the set for the rest of the day
and that's exactly what I wanted you
know including him walking off the set
because at a certain point he knew that
that's the way we're going to do this
guy you know as a guy who used the
n-word and the G word and the S word and
everything else and slapped around
suspects and that's what police work was
then and gene never enjoyed doing that
but he just did it so damn great and
don't think for a moment that I'm
telling you that I coax this performance
out of him what a director does is try
to provide a mood and atmosphere for the
actor to do their best work and
sometimes I don't know if you've ever
had this sometimes it's a question of
conflict you know I remember reading how
Stanley Kubrick got a the young woman
who was in the shining what was her name
Shelley Duvall Shelley Duvall he would
get her crazy yeah you know he would
make her do it again and again and
scream and yell at her and Kubrick
wasn't like that
but he did that with Shelley Duvall and
she gives what I think is a terrific
performance under those harsh
circumstances that's not the way I
recommend working but by any means and
you know it often leads to a crack in
the jaw you know but
just stuck it out and held it held it
together and he had the chops and he
delivered in a way that I I couldn't
even ask